there's no such thing as changing your
why
your why is something objective it's who
you are it's who you are at your natural
best you know you we were all fully
formed uh When We Were Young we are
products of our upbringing
um and and we can make tactical changes
but fundamentally who we are is who we
are
um and and putting your why into words
is putting that into words so uh once
it's written you can tweak the language
for sure and find Nuance but there's no
changing it so if you're changing it
every year probably not your why
um but I can tell you a fun little
exercise if you want to learn your why
uh I call it the friends test
uh call a friend who you love someone
who you could call them at three o'clock
in the morning or they could call you at
three o'clock in the morning you would
absolutely take the call do not do this
with a spouse or a sibling those
relationships are too close because they
know you do too well
um do with a best friend and ask them
this simple question
um why are we friends
and they're gonna look at you like
you're crazy
uh because you're asking them to put
into words something that exists in the
emotional part of their brain the
Olympic brain but that part of the brain
doesn't control language the neocortex
and so they're going to say I don't know
why are you asking me you say come on
just just humor me and then weirdly you
stop asking the question why you ask the
question what it elicits better answers
come on what specifically is it about me
that I know that you would be there for
me no matter what and they'll start
describing you I don't know I can trust
you you're smart you're funny and you
play Devil's Advocate great that's a lot
of friends what specifically is about me
and they're going to go through a few
rounds of Heming and hawing and
eventually they'll give up and
eventually they'll give up and start
describing themselves and this is what
my friend said to me I don't know Simon
all I know is I can just sit in a room
with you I don't even have to talk to
you and I feel inspired and I got
goosebumps in fact I'm getting them
right now
and if you do this with multiple friends
you'll get very similar if not the exact
same answer because what they're
articulating is your value you have in
the world which is your why so it's a
fun way to get at it if that's if you're
interested in it